Korean food really labor of love my name
is Esther Choi I am the chef of mock Bar
and miss you in the near city and we are
making beef up evening Bob is called PB
Bob because PV names to mix so it
literally means mixed rice the beauty of
PB bub is that you can use any vegetable
that you want and it's a great leftover
dish I make all the vegetables in
advance and we've been in my fridge so
all you have to do is fry up an egg and
cook rice and you can't have people bub
for a week I always cook since I was
very young and my grandma was a
phenomenal cook and she was the one that
raised us because my parents were
immigrants and they were always working
so I hung out with my grandparents
growing up and my grandma would just
cook all the time that was her thing can
she like grew on her own vegetables she
made everything from scratch I would
just be drawn to the kitchen all the
time my sister and my brother was so not
like that I would just always hang out
in the kitchen with my grandma you can
use fresh turkey if you want I just love
love love the texture of the dried
shiitakes these ones are a little bit
different than the fresh shiitake is
that you got here
it's like much more meteor I actually
went to college and try to do normal
corporate thing and it just wasn't for
games like you know what I think I'm
just gonna go cook I always have a
restaurant job since I was 14 I was
either large ending or serving or
hostess say I think the first day that I
trailed in a real New York City kitchen
is when I was like no this is what I
want to do one of the best memories I
have growing up with grandma we would
make dumplings together and I have a
dish my dumplings are called grandma
dumplings and Koreans called harmonii
dumplings honey meaning grandma all the
kimchi's all her recipes most of them
are inspired by grandma when she visits
the restaurants like this needs to be
better to the Pelisson and all these
things my mom used to make this race for
me every day growing up it's just a
blend of black rice white
and it's super nutritious the color is
really beautiful I just love it that you
eat with your eyes first presentation is
always super important
now you can like mess up your creation
rate the proper way of Ignis is to fix
everything a big fight
[Music]
oh yes